just a word of introduction for someone
who needs no introduction Sharon Coogler
gales university chaplain is our speaker
today I just wanted to tell you a little
bit about my observations of Sharon in
the last week or so when i started in
chaplaincy my mentor father Jack Kelly
said that chaplains at universities work
for five days a year and the rest is fun
but those five days are the worst five
days of your life and Sharon this last
two weeks has done incredible work that
she can't talk about and I can't talk
about behind the scenes to help with any
lays family after her murder and then
with Sylvia Bingham's death this week
Sylvia Bingham 09 she's done a lot with
incredible kindness love but also
strength the strength that you need to
get through these things and it's a
privilege to have her here Yale for me
to work with her and for us to have her
here at the university church Sharon
thank you for those kind words Ian the
whole chaplaincy staff has been truly
heaven-sent this week just two weeks ago
this sermon was going to be about
something else two weeks ago I was
imagining a beautiful late-september day
and our almost childlike wonder at
finding ourselves together worshiping in
this tent why are we in a tent who is in
Patel how did this come about what does
this mean these were the questions I was
looking forward to pondering with you
these were the questions that were
inspiring my reflections on the text of
the day and yet now why who how what
those same interrogatives are still
there with us yet in a very different
context there is a kind of fragility in
the air right now that defies
description we have all been touched by
deep deep sorrow each of us in our own
way some of us are fearful and cannot
wrap our minds much less our spirits
around the events of the last several
days Annie lays death has shaken us to
our core and reminded us of an
all-too-common darkness that we sell
them have to directly encounter much
less touch here in what some have called
the Yale bubble and yet somewhere every
minute in our world unspeakable
senseless violence happens we find
ourselves asking the questions of the
ages about good and evil chance and
Providence and how they manifest
themselves in our world we are not
asking them in the abstract now these
questions are very real to us and they
have a human face I know my dear sisters
and brothers that I cannot make sense of
what happened to Annie for you much less
for myself nor can i or
will I tie it up in a neat theological
bow for you or me to swallow and then
move on I can only speak to our human
response to unbearable heartbreak as a
chaplain I view it is nothing short of a
sacred privilege to be with someone in a
time of sorrow and loss the time passes
in a series of moments moments which are
heartbreaking overwhelming leaving me
feeling helpless to ease the pain yet
the moments are most certainly holy holy
may seem like an odd description for
such a thing but it is what I know to be
true these moments open us to each other
and to what is really real in ways that
can't often be explained and maybe
shouldn't be these moments are not lived
in our heads they are experienced in our
breathing in and in our breathing out
although there were difficult
distractions from the media and rampant
rumor there was holiness the fragility
in the air lent itself to perhaps a
deeper kind of mindfulness and how we
are present with one another we held
hands tighter we hugged longer we
breathe in and out with purpose and yes
even gratitude Annie's family and all
who knew her are left to pick up pick up
the pieces of their future born out of
this tragedy but we are here to help
this is what the human family does and
has done for as long as our stories have
unfolded we stand with each other arms
firmly holding each other up we comfort
each other and we get on down on our
knees if one of us has fallen this
morning in our second lesson James asks
us who is wise and understanding among
you show by your good life that your
works are done with gentleness born of
wisdom
he cautions us not to live in our heads
that wisdom is understood in our
behavior again James but the wisdom from
above is first pure than peaceable
gentle willing to yield full of mercy
and good fruits without a trace of
partiality or hypocrisy James does not
skirt the issue of evil he faces it head
heads on and he points to its potential
in each one of us the great
spiritualists and sage to Martin Luther
King jr. the Reverend Howard Thurman
gives us an eloquent description of what
it means to foster wisdom from above as
one walks through the twist in terms of
life he writes I seek a gracious spirit
in dealing with the in justices of the
world this I do not confuse with
softness or fear or cowardness or
sentimentality I must know clearly the
evilness of evil and recognize it for
what it is stark brutal terrifying I
must oppose it and place full weight of
whatever forces I have thoroughly
against it at the same time I cannot
exceed escape the fact that every
judgment is a self judgment that even as
I resist evil I share the guilt of evil
it is this sense of sharing the guilt of
evil that should inspire the gracious
spirit in dealing with injustice James
beckons us draw near to God draw near to
God those are the words that fueled my
soul these last several days as God's
own presence was what held so many
during our collective shock when tragedy
strikes we stand at the crossroads
between hope and despair torn and
hurting despair cements us and the
present hope on the other hand sends us
to look around dark corners trusting in
a tomb
morrow we cannot see a tomorrow that may
at this moment seemed terribly
precarious and uncertain long ago i
learned that hope and despair not
opposites they are cut from the same
cloth made from the same material shaped
from the very same circumstances most of
all every life finds itself forced to
choose one from another one day at a
time one circumstance after another the
only difference between the two is that
despair shapes an attitude of the mind
whereas hope creates a quality of a soul
despair colors the way we look at things
makes us fearful and suspicious of the
future it coaxes us into a feeling of
powerlessness with the present the death
of an eel a signaled a sudden ending and
rendered each of us stunned and sour
full we as a family as a community felt
profound to sprayer we froze in our
tracks what could such senseless
violence mean how could it happen here
how could it happen within the fold we
were forced to ask ourselves where is
the light where is the hope in all our
intellectual sophistication we are often
without words dumbfounded in the face of
life and death we frantically search for
ways to dull the pain and this can take
on different forms we might lash out we
might retreat we must seek to be wise
instead of simply smart we must save her
a continual hunger for something more we
must allow ourselves to be restored it
is essential that we continue to long
for experiences of joy and comfort to
listen for the healing voice of God in
the silence of our souls this is what
will make us new again many of us saw on
monday night at annies vigil that we
can't get there by walking through the
pain alone we must get there as a
community yes we felt completely
off-balance and yes the last few days
words and reason have failed us but we
have never been abandoned God's abiding
love has been and continues to be
fertile in the darkness we have shed
tears and we need to be held close by
one another there is profound sorrow but
there is also human connection and
through that connection there is hope
the late theologian and poet henri
nouwen wrote hope means to keep living
amid desperation and to keep humming in
the darkness hope is knowing there is
love it is a trust in tomorrow it is
falling asleep and waking again when the
Sun rises in the midst of a gay lat see
it is to discover land in the eyes of
another it is to see that you are
understood as long as there is still
hope there will also be prayer and you
will be held in God's own hands my
sisters and brothers together we are
back into a new beginning a beginning
that for many of us may feel beyond our
strength we are summoned to hope again
to want tomorrow to celebrate the lives
of an eel a and Sylvia Bingham in our
tomorrows hope takes life in its own
terms it knows that whatever happens God
lives in it and hope expects love will
conquer evil and that always always we
are never alone despair says there is no
where to go but here hope says that our
tender loving God is waiting for us
somewhere else the impassioned prayer of
Howard Thurman was to ask God to match
our darts of despair with the treasures
of our dreams we need to take each
other's hand and begin let us begin
again to hope let us dream let us draw
near to God finally I'm so very grateful
that this sunday is a Eucharist sunday
for we need to be around this table
desperately right now as we draw near to
God around the table in this tent let me
point to mark's gospel which is such a
beautiful illustration illustration of
servant leadership or social status even
religious affiliation is far from the
point we are in this tent this morning
because our Jewish brothers and sisters
needed the considerable space that Patel
chapel offers in order to celebrate Rosh
Hashanah our Muslim community who
normally uses Patel in the evening
during Ramadan to break their fast we're
over at st. Thomas More last night for
the same reason we as richly diverse
religious communities are demonstrating
holy hospitality in numerous settings
and though it has been chaotic to
conceptualize and even to orchestrate
this morning it somehow feels just right
walls do not make a church you and I
make church through selfless acts of
love and welcome it has been written
that radical servant leadership is not
just for the church it is also the
witness of the church to the world you
my beloved sisters and brothers of
university church are a beautiful
embodiment of this witness today you
welcome the stranger you make room for
the other and you are walking humbly
with your God amen